The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: So let's do
a really fast estimation
to just make sure you're
up to speed on solar facts.
So how big a solar
panel do you need
to power a 100-Watt
incandescent light bulb?
Does anyone remember
the flux, solar flux?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, 1,000 Watts
per meter squared, exactly.
And efficiency?
STUDENT: 20.
AMY BANZAERT: 20%, 10%, 20%.
So to make it really easy
to math, lets go with 10.
So that would be 100
Watts per meter squared,
and we have a 100 light bulb.
So assuming there's no
other inefficiency losses,
and we're just going directly
from solar panel to light bulb
for lighting in the middle of
the day-- very common need--
that would be a 1 meter panel,
or 1 meter squared panel.
So I think the solar
options that we
covered last week are Sotus.
And I didn't have
time before class,
but I'll try to hunt
one down during the lab,
an example of a [? Sotus ?]
bag that a student invented.
That's kind of cool to see.
Then there's solar
thermal and PV.
And so there was a confusion
about the difference
between solar thermal and PV.
So fundamentally,
solar thermal is just
using the greenhouse
effect to get something hot
and use that heat, as opposed
to PV, stands for photovoltaics.
And that means you're taking
the photons from the sun,
and converting that using a
semiconductor material that
has a photovoltaic behavior
to get an electric current out
from those photons.
So those are quite distinct--
heat versus electricity.
And so solar
thermal is typically
used for things
like heating water
because it's really
easy to heat the water,
well, relatively easy to
heat the water with the sun.
And then it's just direct.
So here's an example
of you have your panel,
which is not a photovoltaics
panel, but just
a panel where you have a
volume of water that's probably
in a box that has
black behind it
so you're maximizing
your solar radiation.
Your cold water goes in.
The water heats up.
Your hot water comes out, and
it goes into your hot water
storage tank.
There are, of course, many
ways to make this much more
complicated so that you
get different benefits,
but that would be a simple
way to think about it.
And out in the Mojave Desert,
there's a 350 megawatt
peak output solar
thermal installation.
This is a little
complicated because they're
using the hot water, which
is steam, to power a turbine.
And that turbine
creates electricity.
So that's one way of
getting electricity out
of solar thermal, but it's
indirect, unlike photovoltaics.
So that's the distinction.
And in terms of developing
world applications,
I hope I have some at the end.
But if not, it's
really common to,
if you want a hot
shower, to just
have a big bag on your roof.
And it heats up, and then
you get hot water for
as long as that bag lasts, and
then it's cold water again.
So that's one example
that's common.
And then I'll talk about some
PV applications in a bit.
So I wanted to do a quick
overview of photovoltaics.
So basically, again,
the photovoltaic effect
is being taken advantage
of to generate electricity.
This says in silicone.
There's a lot of different
photovoltaic materials
I'll touch base on really fast.
There's also confusion
about what this junction is.
The junction is
emphasized on the slide
because it's where the
interesting stuff happens
in the cell.
But it's just where the two
slightly different layers
of silicon interact generally.
There's generally not a
special separate material
there, though this
is complicated
because we're
generalizing, and there's
a lot of different silicon
in photovoltaic materials.
And different ones
behave differently.
But generally--
so I'm just going
to talk about a
traditional silicon cell
because it's very
common and easy.
So you have silicon that on the
top side has been doped in such
a way that's called "n-type."
So it means that it attracts
more negative electrons.
And the bottom side has
been doped the opposite way,
so called "p-type" for positive.
So it's attracting more
positive electrons.
And so you can imagine
if negative, positive,
you're creating flow.
And that's critical because
you need the flow in order
to get the electricity
out of the cell.
So you can see here
you've got your n-type
on top, your p-type on bottom.
That's the junction where
the positive electrons
are going down.
The negative electrons
are going up.
And we're getting
electric flow, which
is providing your electricity
to light your light bulb
or whatever you want.
So you can think
of this as a diode
because it's allowing
directional flow,
like we talked about a
light-emitting diode.
It's just an
electricity-emitting diode
is one way, maybe,
of thinking about it.
So there's a bunch of
different materials.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So are you saying
the n-type attracts negative,
or it is negative, so
it attracts [INAUDIBLE]..
AMY BANZAERT: So the--
can I remember this--
the n-type has more--
I can't even remember
because so it's not critical.
There's a difference.
They flow.
Does anyone remember?
STUDENT: The [INAUDIBLE]
is [INAUDIBLE]
more like those [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Thanks.
So yeah.
So the efficiency
is really going
to vary depending
on the material
and how carefully
it was processed.
And "carefully"
translates to cost.
And the other thing
to remember is
that it's dependent on light
normal or perpendicular
to the surface.
So that's why you have to tilt
your solar panels into the sun,
and why some arrays that
are expensive automatically
tilt themselves.
Other ones you just
put on the house
or wherever you're putting it at
the maximum angle for the most
amount of time.
But if you don't put it in the
right place or the right angle,
you're really going to minimize
the efficacy of the cell.
Someone wanted to know, is
it just silicon that's used?
No, silicon is most
popular right now.
But you can see there are some
other materials, some of which
are more experimental
than others.
And I'm sure there's additional
examples that I don't even
have on here.
But there's a lot of
different materials used.
All of the pros and
cons, for example--
cadmium is pretty
toxic if it gets out,
but hopefully it doesn't.
But it's all challenging.
So how solar-- yeah.
STUDENT: So you use
silicon because it's
a good semiconductor?
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
Exactly, so silicon is
a good semiconductor.
And a semiconductor means it's
not a full conductor like, say,
a copper wire.
And it's not a full insulator
like, say, the plastic
around your copper wire.
It somewhat conducts,
and that allows
you to do cool things like
having the photovoltaic effect.
STUDENT: So that wouldn't
work if it was completely
like a conductor?
AMY BANZAERT:
Complete conductors
don't have a
photovoltaic effect.
I think it's a good
way to think about it.
Do you agree?
STUDENT: I think you
might be able to make--
you said [INAUDIBLE],,
but I don't
you-- you can't [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Right, exactly.
So--
STUDENT: There's no energy gap.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
all right, thank you
for helping me with that.
So the clarification is
that the semiconductor
allows you to create flow
so that when you excite
the electrons in the material,
they have to go somewhere
in order to be useful.
And if it's fully conductive,
you can't change--
how we talked about--
so this is doped
differently than this.
So you have a negative
side or positive side
to allow for flow.
You couldn't do that
in a full conductor.
But you can with
a semiconductor.
Come on, little laptop.
OK, so photovoltaics
is generally
wiring a bunch of
solar cells together.
You guys wired in
series, I believe,
but they're typically wired
in series or parallel.
And I'll get into
that in just a sec.
And then you can
take those panels
and wire them together
into big, enormous systems.
And one of the things
that's been challenging
is that they're
sensitive to temperature.
And so for example, in
areas where it's really hot,
where there's a lot of sun,
that'd be a great place
to put a solar panel
except they get too hot,
and then they get
less efficient.
So they're really frustrating.
There were some questions on
series versus parallel wiring.
And hopefully, this is
just a quick review.
But if you put two
cells in series,
the voltage is additive.
And so we have two 6-volt
350 amp-hour cells.
You put them together and
you're getting 12 volts.
Whereas if you wire
them in parallel,
the voltage isn't
additive, the current is.
And if you put them in
series and parallel, which
is how they're commonly
wired, then you
get the voltage and the current
you actually need, ideally.
However, the thing
to always remember
with solar cells, which
hopefully you'll notice today,
is that if you cover
one of the panels up,
that drops the
current in that panel,
and it affects all the panels
when they're wired in series.
And so it's a really
frustrating reality
that they all need
to be equally clear.
So the components
of a solar system--
you have a panel, you
have the regulator,
which typically has the
components inside it
so that you make sure
that the electricity is
flowing in just one
direction, as we talked about.
That goes to some
sort of storage.
And then, it goes to an inverter
if you need AC appliances.
You can see that all of
these different components
have efficiencies.
So every single one is
going to drop your--
afraid to click too many times--
is going to drop your
efficiency, which
is really frustrating.
So again, you have
grid-tied systems
just like we've had everything
else, or you have standalone,
or you have hybrid.
I'm not going to talk
about grid because we don't
do that much in this class.
But for standalone systems,
you have your charge controller
going to your battery
and then an inverter,
so just what we talked about.
And I don't know why
today is going so poorly,
but it really is.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So for a
cell phone charger,
you will need not
only some resistance
to get the total
resistance right,
but you'd also
need that inverter.
AMY BANZAERT: So
hypothetically, yeah.
People do all sorts
of bad practices
and get away with it,
for better or for worse.
So for example,
the battery charger
I showed from [INAUDIBLE]
Phoenix on Wednesday
is literally just a panel
with a couple of wires
coming out, going
to a place where
you can charge your batteries.
Which means that it has great
possibility for failure,
but it's really cheap.
And so there's always
that trade-off,
of you can take something
and it'll be super cheap,
and that's handy, but
it won't work very well.
And you have to figure
out what you want.
You can make this
a $10 million--
that'd be hard, but $1,000
system or a $1 system,
and there's real trade-offs in
terms of cost and performance.
STUDENT: But it still
works as direct current?
AMY BANZAERT: Well, so batteries
only need direct current.
So they're getting
direct current,
whereas this computer's
expecting alternating current.
So I'd need a special device if
I wanted to use direct current.
Computer's a bad example
because of the Cube
that actually does take
direct current, too.
But this projector would
need a special device
to get direct current.
And so of course,
you can see extremes
from a standalone system
in Bangladesh all the way
to 10 megawatt solar array.
So this is in Abu Dhabi.
So I don't want to
take the time to go
through this whole question, but
it'll be in the lecture notes
that I'll post today.
And I think I'll post
them in week four,
because this was the solar
lecture that never was,
but it makes sense to
put in the solar week.
But if you can go
through it, this actually
walks you through it.
But I recommend doing
it like we do in class.
So try to do it, and
then if you get stuck,
you can go through it.
But this is good practice,
especially because the homework
has been dying out
in order to make
sure you guys have enough
time to get all the work done.
But this is a helpful
calculation to be able to do.
So developing world
applications--
just quickly, what do you
think people tend to use solar
for in developing countries?
STUDENT: Water heaters.
AMY BANZAERT: Water
heaters, what else?
STUDENT: Light.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah.
STUDENT: Cellphone chargers.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah,
so TV is asking
a lot out of a solar panel.
You might see it, but it's
going to be expensive.
And you certainly wouldn't
see a refrigerator on here
because again,
that's getting really
expensive in terms of the
size of the panel you need.
And some examples that
we've talked about,
but I just wanted to
refresh your memory on--
so one is Grameen Shakti in
Bangladesh, where women wire up
the solar panels.
They use micro-financing to
make the panels affordable.
They're often in
little markets where
people buy little amounts of
food and things like that.
They can also
access electricity,
or the market can just
have light on at night.
And they also do
micro-utilities, too.
I believe there's about 1,000
micro-utilities operating
in Bangladesh.
I'm not sure how they
pronounce themselves,
but this group in Brazil, and
they do a fee-for-service,
where the company is
responsible for the care
of the battery,
which is critical
because the batteries
require care.
And if they're not
well cared for,
you can cut their life
by half, if not more.
And they're a pretty
expensive part of a system.
They work on a
flexible payment system
so that the customer decides.
Because some people
work in areas
where you might make most
of your money in one month.
And so if you're
expected to pay month
by month, that can
be really tough,
but if you can just pay
once a year, it works.
And then they do a
lot of user education
to help make sure people use
them effectively and care
for them properly.
SELCO we also talked
about, in India.
And they have lots
of different examples
from lighting in a temple,
sorting cocoons for silk
industry, in houses,
in marketplaces.
We talked about DLight Design.
And they have lights that
come with the solar panel
or have the solar panel
integrated into the light,
so people have a light
option even if they
don't have a home installation.
One of the challenges with
solar like this-- and you'll
see it a lot.
People have it on
their bags or you
can buy a charger or
solar panel that you
can put wherever-- is it
requires you to be outside
or it to be outside.
And so it's challenging.
I always have a flashlight
that has a solar panel on it.
And I stopped bringing
it on my field work
because I'm not necessarily
outside the whole day.
And I can't just leave
it there, or else it
will walk if I don't
keep an eye on it.
And that's true for everyone.
And so that's one of the
frustrating things about solar
generally, is that the panel is
expensive and worth something
whether it's integrated
into the device or not.
And so figuring out how
you keep the panel secure--
it's easy to stick a battery
inside a secure room,
but not so easy to stick a
panel inside a secure room that
has no roof.
So that's challenging.
And they tend to be
small enough that they're
easier to steal than,
say, like a wind turbine
or something like that.
The Solar Thermal Group,
which is an MIT project--
this is an example of using
solar thermal in a developing
country.
And they have a wide variety of
applications of different ways
that they use the solar thermal.
But some of which I think is
electricity generating as well,
from the steam.
So that does have a
real world application.